l'otan met en garde elle prévient l
annonce
elle entre dans un jeu de coopération
entre 30 et à illies a effectivement une
entre guillemets une menace sécuritaire
sur l'europe de l'ouest
bon ba aujourd'hui effectivement dans un
conseil comme un sommet qui vient
d'avoir lieu
il est difficile pour les états membres
de ne pas désigner quelqu'un ou à un
état qui effectivement depuis quelques
années depuis 2014
depuis la crimée montre une certaine
certaines velléités de puissance donc
l'otan est une alliance défensive
militaire j'ai bien dit défensive
donc il est normal qu'elle s'exprime sur
un point sans forcément faire de la
russie
l'ennemi premier l'ennemi réel mais
c'est une mise en garde en tout cas
clairement le but affiché était de
resserrer en ces alliances pour contrer
c'est qu'on les appelle comme on veut
les ennemis les rivaux la chine la
russie pourquoi est-ce aussi important
chez régis chamagne
de se défendre entre guillemets de la
russie c'est important pour les états
unis l'otan est une organisation sous
leadership américain
depuis le début il faut bien considérer
que les autres pays de l'otan sont des
vassaux et cela se retrouve dans les
structures de commandement et donc tous
les postes importants qui sont occupées
au sein de la chaîne de commandement de
l'otan les postes importants sont
occupés par des officiers d'amérique et
les autres sont des vassaux et
normalement l'otan aurait dû disparaître
après la chute de l'urss
puisque l'otan a été créée en 1949 pour
faire face à une attaque potentielle de
l'urss contre l'un des pays du monde
occidental du monde libre donc comme on
disait à l'époque et après la chute de
l'urss l'otan n'avait plus sa raison
d'être
je me souviens avoir participé à un
stage de l'otan en janvier 97 à
oberammergau une station un an deux ans
ou dans les apple d'aaland
et à l'époque il y avait véritablement
une crise dans l'otan parce que ils se
cherchaient des démissions de nouvelles
missions il y avait une crise
existentielle de l'otan et tous les
officiers de l'otan était perdue êtes en
pleine crise existentielle il se disait
nous devons continuer à exister parce
que notre organisation fonctionne oui
mais c'est pas une raison aussi
l'appli ductilité ya pas de raison de la
conserver et du coup d'autant c'est
cemac eu comme toute structure qui
cherche à se maintenir en vie elle sait
chercher d'autres missions et plus
seulement défensive mais offensive
également puisqu'elle était intervenu en
afghanistan on peut pas dire que
l'afghanistan menace les pays d'europe
et les etats-unis ou le canada
donc je pense que là il ya on est dans
un on est dans une situation où les
états unis à travers l'otan maintienne
une vassalisation militaire
sur les pays occidentaux et nous enfin
en tout cas nous français si nous nous
positionnons par rapport à l'histoire à
la longue histoire de france nous
n'avons aucun intérêt à rester dans
cette organisation vraiment aucun et
beaucoup de pays européens comme nous
n'ont aucun intérêt mais il se trouve
qu'au cours des trente quarante
dernières années il ya eu un changement
dans je dirais la politique d' influence
américaine en europe et en particulier
en france a été très efficace ce qui a
mené à aux élections de nicolas sarkozy
de françois hollande et d'emmanuel macro
qui sont complètement dans les petits
toutous des américains c'est trop facile
de connaître son opinion sur ce que vous
venez de nous dire aucun intérêt en tout
cas pour vous des pays européens et
notamment la france a de rester dans
l'otan va justement écouter l'américain
au chef le président joe biden
ce matin avant donc sap réunion depuis
quelques années on voit de plus en plus
que nous avons de nouveaux défis à
relever
et nous avons la russie qui n'agit pas
d'une manière conforme à ce que nous
avions espéré tout comme la chine là il
vient de répondre à régis à magnin
président américain le défi c'est
évidemment la russie et la chine où une
raison d'être d'exister pour pour l'otan
françois chambon si oui alors d'abord
j'aimerais réagir à ce que dit régis
chamagne parce que vous n'êtes peut-être
pas exagérer que les américains est une
certaine mainmise sur l'otan c'est
indéniable mais que nous n'ayons pas les
potes commandement à la hauteur de nos
responsabilités c'est un peu faux il ya
deux grands postes de commandement un
tenu par un américain sa cour et un
tenus par les français à norfolk bon
deux postes 50 % pour la france je pense
quand même d'une certaine forme de
répartition à peu près équitable à notre
bénéfice
deuxième point cassante d'état n'aurait
pas intérêt à rester dans l'otan je n'y
crois pas il suffit de regarder chaque
fois que la france propose une certaine
c'est un dégagement de l'otan à chaque
fois la grande majorité des états de
l'europe de l'otan disent non on reste
parce que les américains par leur
puissance militaire sont une garantie et
puis n'y a pas que cela
les américains ont quand même une
certaine tendance à savoir décider à
savoir agir
ce qui dans une europe à 26 ou à 28
n'est pas tout à fait possible il ya
toujours une raison pour ne pas agir
finalement les américains sont des
agitateurs entre guillemets de la prise
de décision voilà alors maintenant
effectivement pour revenir à la russie
et à la chine
je pense pas que la russie soit
considéré comme une menace principale de
l'europe
la seule différence c'est qu'à l'aide
est à la frontière comme est à la
frontière
ça bouge il ya le premier l'ukraine
comme n'avait pas évoqué qui est quand
même un sujet important
donc il faut pas oublier d'ukraine et
puis surtout une vraie réalité
la chine est une menace aujourd'hui est
d'ailleurs gerra même que la russie
devrait s'inquiéter
la chine est une menace elle est une
menace pas forcément militaire la date
d'aujourd'hui à 60 elle est une menace
économique elle est une menace d'
influence et à ce titre là on peut
comprendre que
l'otan s'en préoccupent maintenant pour
agir aussi encore régis chamagne qui dit
qui évoque effectivement le besoin de se
trouver un ennemi d'ailleurs la question
de la vie poser tout à l'heure non une
réalité
l'otan est une alliance vivante c'est
une alliance vivant qui évoluent là nous
sommes dans l' écriture finalement du
concept stratégique 2030 il ne faut pas
l'oublier
les orientations ont été données en 2019
il est normal que toute alliance
militaire car c'est une alliance
militaire défensive évoluer estime les
menaces à venir et je crois que c'est là
le rôle de l'otan
donc le temps est utile pour ça ça ne
veut pas dire préparer la guerre c'est
simplement faire ce qu'il faut pour
qu'elle n'arrive pas et je crois que
tous les adversaires potentiels qui
puisse exister à court ou à moyen terme
sinon à long terme d'un rang prendre
conscience en tout cas beaucoup disent
que l'otan s'est un peu éloigné de son
but originel y compris emmanuel macron
que l'on écoutait je pense que l'otan
aujourd'hui dans une situation qui
nécessite une très grande clarification
stratégique
l'otan a été construit pour faire face
au pacte de varsovie
elle s'est structurée idéologiquement
dans ce face à face il n'est plus on a
besoin de dire qui est notre ennemi et
où la chine n'est pas dans la géographie
atlantique ou alors ma carte à un
problème existe chaman clairement l'otan
besoin d'une clarification au
stratégique aujourd'hui
alors d'abord je voudrais dire que
l'otan ne sais pas pour semer contre le
pacte de varsovie mais c'est le
contraire le temps été créée en 1949 le
pacte de varsovie en 1955 où 56 donc
emmanuel macron et un problème avec
l'histoire
s'agissant des postes de commandement je
voudrais répondre avec hp lancées et
dire que le poste de norfolk n'est pas
dans la chaîne opérationnelle
c'est le poste essentiel qu'au moment de
la transformation des gect parler de
commandement opérationnel au début juste
que ça ensuite votre question je veux
excuse-moi aimé qu'on dit clairement que
l'otan besoin aujourd'hui d'une
clarification stratégique en clair on
s'est un petit peu
wegnez du but originel est ce que vous
partagez ce diagnostic du président
français oui on s'en est tellement
éloignés que comme je l'aï dit au départ
l'otan de mon sens raison d'être
ce sont des travers le temps à travers
les buts stratégies et les orientations
stratégiques de l'otan ce sont les
intérêts des états unis qui parle est
évidemment aujourd'hui les états unis
sentent bien que la russie est la
première puissance militaire au monde
d'un point de vue qualitatif
donc ils sont dépassés la chine je parle
bien d'un point de vue qualitatif à la
première puissance militaire du monde
les dernières les derniers matériels ni
landunvez développé par la russie sont
très largement supérieur au matériel
américain le f 35 est une est un échec
absolu et tous les derniers
développements américains sont ont
mauvais pas actuel on l'a chiffres d'adp
la russie est la première puissance
militaire au monde d'un point de vue
qualitatif et la chine monte en
puissance et l'air quand mon avis encore
loin d'y arriver mais elle présentait
une menace
je ne suis pas certain que l'on puisse
considérer que des pays qui se
développent des grands pays qui se
développent constitue une menace ça
c'est la vision américaine
la vision d'une amérique qui veut
dominer le monde et être la seule
puissance dominant le monde
effectivement qui considère que quand un
géant comme la chine ou comme la russie
se redresse
ça constitue le las de mon point de vue
ça n'en constitue pas là la chine
effectivement à de gros potentiel mais
elle a énormément de grands étaient là
également je veux dire de grande
fragilité comme par exemple sa capacité
à nourrir sa population
l'autosuffisance de la chine en matière
de nourriture par la suffisance de la
chine en matière de nourriture et aux
alentours de 60%
donc c'est un pays très fragile sur
certains dans certains domaines et
considérer que ce pays
prétexte qu'il se relève serait une
menace est à mon avis une grande erreur
de jugement
nous ferions mieux de disney avec ces
pays plutôt que de les considérer comme
de potentiels ennemi françois chavance y
est ce que ce n'est pas un petit peu
l'échec les européens finalement au fond
l'otan on sait que emmanuel macron le
premier rêver d'une grande europe de la
défense qui a bien du mal à voir le jour
oui c'est ce que j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure quand on a 30 et adam une
alliance dont le canada et les états
unis
il est certain que mettre tout le monde
d'accord c'est difficile bon maintenant
pour revenir sur la question de la
menace chinoise
pour l'instant les actions je dirais
militarisée en mer de chine méridionale
pose problème aujourd'hui de jour en
jour de semaine en semaine
y compris pour les forces françaises
dépensent navale il y à des risques
d'affrontement
et il faut bien en prendre conscience
alors au dire que la chine n'est pas une
menace
dès lors qu'elle a des ambitions
territoriales y compris maritime
je ne doute je pense qu'il faut appeler
ça une menace maintenant la question
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure et
peut-être beaucoup plus importante
la question est celle et gerland
d'ailleurs régis tchaman sur ce point là
quelles sont les limites de l'otan
jusqu'à ou devons-nous aller en terme
d'intervention nous sommes allés en
afghanistan s'était pas franchement le
but puis traité de l'alliance d'un
portique nord
nous y sommes allés maintenant il faut
de se demander pourquoi on y est allés
effectivement une influence américaine
une influence aussi en partie d'ailleurs
les français ont abondé dans ce sens il
ya comme une réaction et penser là je
reviens à votre question à vous la
défense de l'europe pose problème
aujourd'hui et nous n'arrivons pas à
créer une vraie défense européenne
l'union européenne est incapable d'avoir
une défense commune pour plein de
raisons différentes
en revanche l'otan est le seul organisme
militaire dans lequel effectivement tout
et nation trouvent leur place plus ou
moins importante en fonction du budget
en fonction des compétences et autres
donc l'otan et pour ça un outil
irremplaçable non pas parce que c'est le
meilleur mais simplement parce qu'il
existe et qu'il a fait ses preuves
effectivement 1949 il à empêcher la
guerre en
et pour l'instant effectivement on
évolue vers d'autres missions peut-être
d'ailleurs la révolution du traité dont
on ne parle jamais et là je rejoindrai
ce qui a été dit sur la chine ce qui a
été dit sur l'afghanistan il ya un
moment où s'arrête le temps moi
j'interprète ça d'une manière positive
l'otan aujourd'hui est nécessaire
simplement parce qu'elles assurent la
sécurité des états européens
on y associant notamment les états unis
merci en tout cas tous les deux et
françois chavancy régissent le chaman
d'avoir été avec nous pour débattre de
la nécessité de l'utilité de cette
organisation atlantique merci à vous et
le saumon réaction de vladimir poutine
interviewé par la chaîne américaine nbc
le chef du kremlin juge notamment
grotesque de dire que la russie mène une
guerre informatique contre les états
unis
même s'il se montre ferme au sujet des
problèmes de sécurité deux présidents se
lit aussi ouvert à la possibilité d'un
échange de prisonniers entre mons et
washington main tendue pour aborder les
points de convergence avec à washington
il s'est exprimé à ce sujet hier chez
nos confrères de rossiya 1 dans
l'émission les américains affirment
qu'un certain nombre de questions
relèvent de nos intérêts mutuels et je
suis d'accord avec eux il s'agit entre
autres de la stabilité stratégique de la
résolution des conflits régionaux de la
protection globale de l'environnement
il y à des questions sur lesquelles nous
pouvons vraiment coopérer efficacement
soit dit en passant il existe également
d'intérêt mutuel dans le domaine de
l'économie de nombreuses entreprises
américaines souhaitent travailler chez
nous elles sont forcées de quitter notre
marché cèdent leur place à des
concurrents cela profite il vraiment
l'économie américaine
nous avons donc des sujets à traiter et
nous avons des sujets en commun et si
après cette rencontre nous mettons en
place des mécanismes de coopération dans
tous ces domaines on pourra dire que la
rencontre n'a pas été organisée pour
rien
mais si joe biden poursuit sa tournée
européenne outre atlantique ces faits et
gestes ne manque pas d'interpeller
l'ancien président américain donald
trump
la réunion du g7 le week end dernier et
les échanges entre le locataire de la
maison blanche emmanuel macron notamment
provoqué son courroux pour plus de
précisions on retrouve tout de suite
notre reporter thomas abonnés en direct
de washington bonsoir omar qu'est ce qui
a provoqué la colère de de donald trump
et bien comme nous donald trump a vu les
différentes images qui ont été diffusées
des différentes rencontres et les
différentes discussions lors du g7 où on
a pu voir emmanuel macron et joe biden
un très proche mettant en scène une
complicité une proximité même qui a
évidemment un sens politique alors si on
ne nie pas le fait que les deux
présidents puisse avoir de bonnes
relations si rapidement on sent que ces
images visait surtout à servir le
discours avancés par les deux hommes à
savoir l'amérique est de retour plus
proche que jamais de ses alliés écouté
par exemple les propos d' emmanuel
macron dans cette vidéo qu'il a lui-même
posté sur son compte twitter pour tous
ces problèmes nous avons besoin de
coopération et je pense que c'est
formidable que le président américain
fasse partie du club et qu'il soit très
désir de coopérer et je pense que ce que
vous démontrez c'est que le leadership
c'est un partenariat les deux chic et
sport chic
vous avez entendu c'est super d'avoir un
président qui fait partie du club et qui
a le souci de vouloir coopérer bien
cette phrase a particulièrement retenu
l'attention d'un observateur de marque
puisqu'il s'agit de donald trump
l'ancien président américain étant privé
de ses réseaux sociaux c'est par le
biais d'un communiqué qu'il a vivement
réagi directement aux propos de madame
macro écouter
lui et beaucoup d'autres dirigeants
avant lui en france et dans toute
l'europe arnaquer les états unis comme
jamais auparavant
il aime baden parce que maintenant ils
seront autorisés à reprendre leurs
anciennes méthodes d'escroquerie
si j'étais un dirigeant de ces pays moi
aussi je préférais byden au président
trump des critiques très virulentes
disant notamment à s'attaquer à la
diplomatie naissante de joe biden mais
cette attaque cible aussi emmanuel
macron avec qui les relations étaient
parfois compliquées entrent donc
l'ancien président américain et le
président français on se souvient
d'abord de ce qui était présenté comme
une relation spéciale avec ce fameux
dîner à la tour eiffel où il y avait les
deux présidents entourés de leurs
compagnes on se rappelle également que
ma quale tenté de se placer en
interlocuteurs européens privilégié de
donald trump mais les accords avaient
ressurgi notamment à l'occasion de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
c'était en 2018 à new york notamment sur
la question du changement climatique et
puis il ya évidemment le tempérament
tempétueux pardon de donald trump
alors évidemment on peut comprendre
qu'elle macron puisse préférer le calme
de joe biden mais il faudra voir sur la
durée si l'entente n'était que de façade
ce week-end ou s'il y aura de réelles
avancées sur des dossiers concrets et à
suivre donc merci thomas bonnin en
direct de washington rester avec nous
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur cette cacophonie autour du port du
masque en extérieur c'est la date du 1er
juillet
été avancée par le directeur général de
la santé le ministère de la santé lui a
tempéré dans la foulée précisant
qu'aucune décision n'avait été prise
et puis nous parlerons de la loi climat
le sénat entame son en examen et affiche
un discours ambitieux pensait deux
semaines de débats dans l'hémicycle
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtelet c'est par théâtre
comme les autres c'est un théâtre qui
est très diversifiée dans un
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein confinement on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend vous soyez déçu
l'univers uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise
je pense que ça a été bien de continuer
le football pour s'évader un peu aussi
haut niveau au niveau mental
on est tous conscients que le football
ligny tout ce qui est au niveau social
surtout au niveau culture et quel regard
portez-vous sur toutes ces années à
monaco à la juventus en équipe de france
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné en temps
dans tous les contextes et quand on a la
chance de revenir en étant ambassadeur
voir des gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a fait
mais surtout au niveau au niveau
football et ça c'est touchant
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris verra comme le
sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis
c'est que c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer en fait je me suis rendu compte
que ça allait c'était suffisamment
physique pour moi j'ai une vie de
sportif de haut niveau je m'entraîne
tous les jours c'est devenu ma vie la
raison de me lever le matin j'avais
toujours ce vieux rêve de petite fille
de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec le genre d'homme en avait un autre
combat dans ma vie qui est celui de la
sécurité routière s'agit d'un projet de
loi qui vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit re doit
imposer loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
20h30 souhaité bienvenue en direct sur
rt feront si vous nous rejoignez aucune
décision précise le ministère de la
santé temporise au sujet de la fin du
port du masque en extérieur au 1er
juillet une annonce qui intervient après
celle de jérôme scène au monde ce matin
sur rtl le directeur général de la santé
avait indiqué que cette obligation
pouvait être levé au début du mois
prochain si les conditions le permettent
on a un calendrier cohérent progressif
liées à la situation ce calendrier
les français l'ont parfaitement compris
et respecté et donc si tout se passe
bien on lèvera encore un certain nombre
de contraintes le 30 juin
si les conditions le permettent de
mauvaise élève en matière de
déconfinement avec l'arrivée des beaux
jours de nombreuses fêtes illégal
s'organise aux quatre coins de
l'hexagone
difficile dans ce contexte d'assurer le
respect des gestes barrières les détails
avec cyrielle bruit les français
serait-il de moins en moins vigilants
face aux cours aux navires us
al'approche de l'été et face à la baisse
du nombre de patients admis à l'hôpital
un vent de relâchement souffle sur
l'hexagone depuis quelques jours les
fêtes sauvages se multiplient à travers
le pays
dernier exemple en date les soirées
organisées sur l'esplanade des invalides
à paris plusieurs milliers de jeunes se
sont réunis vendredi et samedi
malgré l'interdiction des rassemblements
de plus de 10 personnes la plupart sans
masque ils ont été évacués par les
forces de l'ordre peu avant le début du
couvre-feu
une situation qui soulève la question de
l'efficacité du maintien de certaines
restrictions
on aimerait bien faire comme on veut en
fait ont profité du temps ne pas
on va regarder là en fait ce n'est une
horaire entre ath et là oui c'est encore
possible de respecter les gestes
barrières parce que je pense que les
gens sont quand même responsable ils
n'ont pas envie de d'attraper le virus
maintenant c'est vrai que je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de jeunes qui sont restés
enfermés longtemps et qui ont besoin de
se défouler je pense que ça va être
compliqué de les respecter tout le temps
en fait dans les restaurants quand on va
quand on va pouvoir manger à l'intérieur
bon ça va être compliqué voilà de
toujours les respecter maintenant est ce
que c'est pour ça que l'épidémie va
reprendre et tout ça bon ça c'est une
autre question
selon moi ça va être compliqué de
respecter les gestes barrière puisque ça
fait presque un an que nous en tout cas
les parisiens on est entre guillemets
enfermé on a beaucoup souffert
c'est l'été on a envie de profiter on y
pense toujours parce que ce sont des
règles qu'on nous a données depuis le
début mais c'est dur de respecter reste
à savoir si les événements pourront
rester sous contrôle le 21 juin prochain
lors de la fête de la musique
face aux contraintes strictes du
protocole sanitaire certaines villes
comme strasbourg ou encore trois ont
préféré annuler l'événement et pour en
parler nous sommes avec avec six
poulains éditorialise bonsoir l'écrit
foulard merci avec nous alors dérive sur
rt france le risque d'en laisser aller
général de l'été c'est ce qu'on voit sur
ces images alors à laisser aller général
ou pas je ne sais pas rappelez-vous le
déconfinement l'an dernier c'était jean
castex qui était monsieur déconfinement
et avec l'aide de cabinet de conseil et
finalement en gros c'était après le
confinement il ya plus de gyrus donc
faisons la fête
aujourd'hui on a des dates on a des
horaires il faut respecter tout ça en
une campagne de vaccination en parallèle
un pass sanitaire des qr codes un peu
partout mais on voit que le ras-le-bol
est le même en réalité notamment chez
les jeunes qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi 23 heures en quoi ça changerait
quoi que ce soit d'avoir une heure de
différence deux heures de différence ou
plus de couvre-feu du tout sachant que
certains pays n'ont pas du tout c'est
couvre-feu ou les ont fait de manière
tout à fait différente et on gérer
l'épidémie également donc il ya une
vraie question à la fois sur le bien
fondé de ces mesures au niveau sanitaire
sur l'acceptation de ces mesures aussi
uni
social puisque ce sont des mesures de
contrôle des populations au delà du
sanitaire et puis on voit bien que les
jeunes là ont envie de faire craquer ces
règles là sachant que en extérieur il
n'est pas prouvé que ces rassemblements
ont formé des clusters comme c'est peu
l'autre cas effectivement des fêtes en
intérieur là nous sommes l'été la fête
se passe majoritairement en extérieur et
ce n'est pas du tout la même pour le
virus pour se transmettre
puisque il se transmet majoritairement
en lieu clos visiblement selon les
dernières études donc il ya vraiment je
comprends ce ras-le-bol de la jeunesse
qui a envie de revivre et de faire
casser ces mesures incompréhensible
finalement et qui ont fait peut-être
leurs preuves mais on attend d'avoir
réellement les études scientifiques qui
prouverait que ces horaires 23h21 heures
19 heures avait un sens ou bien si
c'était simplement pour jouer avec les
français comme avec des hamsters dans
une cage on ouvre on ferme on met des
croquettes on les enlève alors pas de
dérogation en tout cas pour l'euro de
foot c'est un message de fermeté pour
tenir à un couvre-feu qui crache un
cracker pardon on le voit de partout
oui alors c'est ce que disait laurent
berger député de la république en marche
matin qu'il faut tenir ce couvre feu
jusqu'à fin juin qu'il faut mettre les
masques en extérieur jusque début
juillet alors que tout ça
scientifiquement encore une fois est
sujet à caution
on a le droit de se poser la question du
bien fondé de ces mesures et on se
demande si finalement ce fait en gardant
le fait d'avoir des dates des des
horaires etc de d'aller lentement vers
la fin de ces mesures
ce n'est pas tout simplement pour ne pas
perdre la face et pour ne pas montrer
que tout ça ne servait pas à grand chose
finalement
donc évidemment que au niveau des
populations le ras-le-bol est palpable
il est réel surtout que en réalité on a
vu la semaine dernière et bien deux
poids deux mesures pour les vip qui
était à roland garros devant le match
nadal djokovic et qui ont vu grâce à
matignon
la prérogative fallait de pouvoir rester
jusqu'à la fin du match alors que les
jeunes qui étaient aux tuileries aux
invalides part donc pour faire la fête
se sont fait déloger par la police donc
on voit bien qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures la façon de faire est très
différente voilà c'était benjamin
griveaux on le voit l'antenne qu'ils
aient merci emmanuel macron pour cette
exceptionnelle soirée de tennis quel
match quelle ambiance quel sport magique
donc s benjamin griveaux qui a appelé
emmanuel macron à ce moment là en disant
ce serait bien qu'on puisse rester
toujours est il que pour les supporters
de l'euro de foot ce ne sera pas la même
il faudra rentrer à partir de 23h donc
on a le droit de se demander si le virus
n'est pas un virus de classe et s'il n'a
pas à voir avec le portefeuille ou avec
les supporters de macron plutôt qu'avec
la santé des uns et des autres et alexis
une dernière petite question autour de
ce sujet puisque l'actualité ça va être
la vaccination des adolescents qui se
trouvera à partir de demain jérôme
salomon d'ailleurs à fait aussi savoir
que cette vaccination devait désormais
s'imposer va falloir maintenant aussi
surtout que le gouvernement convainquent
les les parents n'est ce pas c'est pas
forcément gagner ça n'ont clairement pas
sur la vaccination des plus jeunes le
bénéfice risque reste une grosse
question
on voit clairement qu'il ya là une
offensive de la part du gouvernement
pour faire vacciner les plus jeunes à la
fois ouvrir à partir de 12 ans il faut
le consentement parental mais on voit
bien qu'il ya des petites voix qui
s'élèvent au delà du conseil de
déontologie ou au tracé alain fischer
monsieur vaccin qui dit oui de manière
arithmétique il serait logique de
vacciner les plus jeunes même si en fait
ils ne risquent rien avec ce virus
mais comme il le transmettent il
faudrait les vacciner le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a des chiffres qui
sortent des laboratoires qui disent qu
effectivement ce vaccin pour les jeunes
n'est pas si grave mais c'est des
chiffres qui sortent sur des tests sur
3000 jeunes
il ya des vaccinations massives ça a été
le cas en israël aux états unis et on a
vu là par contre arrivée des cas de
myocardite pour les plus jeunes qui sont
surveillés mais qui sont inquiétants
tout de même alors la question se pose
pourquoi vacciner les plus jeunes pour
protéger les plus je si les plus jeunes
ne risqueraient ainsi on si on ne
faisait que respecter les gestes
barrière pourquoi cet empressement à
vacciner et alain fischer va plus loin
puisque lui parle même de
de d'avoir le vaccin à l'école de
relancer la médecine scolaire grâce à
cette vaccination à l'école sans la
rendre obligatoire puisqu'il dirais que
ce serait difficile aujourd'hui de la
rendre obligatoire mais on voit que tout
est fait pour contraindre pour pousser
pour inciter les français à se vacciner
et à faire vacciner leurs enfants
la question qui se pose c'est est ce que
est ce que c'est ce sera utile
est ce que ce sera surtout efficace si
jamais un nouveau variant arrive
regardez le cas de la grande-bretagne
vacciner à l'astra zeneca certes mais
arrive le variant indien variant delta
et et voilà que les les taux remontent
en flèche ces derniers jours donc rien
rien ne prouve que finalement cette
vaccination avec ces vaccins arn
messagers sera utile efficace pour les
plus jeunes si ce n'est cette
arithmétique de dire qu'il faut vacciner
les plus jeunes pour que 90% de la
population soit vaccinée parce que au
niveau des adultes ça commence à bloquer
merci beaucoup alexis poulain
éditorialistes d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france merci à vous plus
d'un mois après avoir été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale le projet de loi
climat poursuit son chemin les us hâtif
à partir d'aujourd'hui pendant deux
semaines le sénat examine le texte jugé
perfectible par l'opposition de droite
majoritaire au palais du luxembourg et
précision de katia technique le texte
que certains disent vidé de sa substance
sera-t-il plus ou moins vert qu'après
son passage à l'assemblée 700
amendements ont été adoptés et le groupe
écologiste au sénat a tout de même parlé
d'avancées concrètes
la ministre de la transition écologique
barbara pompili a défendu un texte que
certains sénateurs ont désavoué
aujourd'hui ceux ci ont jugé que ce
projet de loi manque d'ambition
dénonçant le poids des lobbys d'autres
surtout chez les républicains souhaitent
que les mesures environnementales soient
compatibles avec la croissance
deux visions opposées qui vont
s'affronter durant quinze jours on
revient déjà de loin avec cette loi
climat et résilience la convention
citoyenne pour le climat mise sur pied à
l'initiative d'emmanuel macron avait
élaboré 149 propositions pour parvenir à
trouver des mesures pour mieux respecter
le climat limiter les gaz à effet de
serre mais l'assemblée n'avait retenu
qu'une quinzaine aux grands
dam des députés d'opposition qui avait
dénoncé un enfumage mais ici ou sénat
les parlementaires souhaitent comme ils
disent enrichir le texte
on écoute stéphane demilly sénateur
centriste c'est un sujet qui est
présenté de façon un peu fourre tout et
pour certains d'entre eux ne va pas
effectivement suffisamment au fond je
pense que parfois il ya un peu trop de
cosmétiques eu l'occasion de beaucoup
intervenir sur l'article 36 qui veut
interdire les vols comme vous savez
quand on peut prendre le train et faire
le parcours en moins de 2h30
je trouve que dit comme cela ça part et
ça paraît très bien sauf que moi je suis
plutôt favorable d'une méthode poule que
tu une méthode push
plutôt que d'interdire l'aviation je
trouve qu'il serait plus intelligent de
pousser nos citoyens à prendre le train
parce que les trains sont à l'heure
parce que les taux de tva sont réduits
et puis ça il ya des propositions en ce
sens et c'est cela en fait que nous
souhaitons faire en l'enrichissant ce
texte alors qu'elle avançait sur ce
texte appauvrit la création d'un chèque
alimentaire le retour de la consigne un
prêt à taux zéro pour l'achat d'un
véhicule peu polluant la rénovation
thermique la protection des forêts des
sols forestiers une mesure abandonnée
par l'assemblée nationale
la baisse de la tva sur les billets de
train et au point de vue des reculs le
menu végétarien à l'école ne sera pas
généralisé seulement reconduit pendant
deux ans pour les collectivités qui le
souhaitent pas d'interdiction d'un
certain type de suremballage la lutte
contre l'artificialisation des sols est
très réduite
il était question aussi pour la viande
de supprimer de nombreuses îles
intérieur si une alternative rapide en
train exister et bien finalement seule
la ligne orly bordeaux va fermer la loi
climat et résilience ne promet donc pas
une révolution
et pour en parler nous sommes avec yves
contassot man 2 générations m onze fois
merci d'être avec nous on a vu un
certain sénateurs qui accuse des députés
d'une certaine frilosité sur cette loi
climat vont vous partager ce sentiment
c'est une grande mascarade cette loi en
gros c'est l'illustration du en même
temps de monsieur maquereau en même
temps on ne fait rien et en même temps
on en parle mais ya rien dans cette loi
qui soit de nature à permettre
d'atteindre les objectifs de la france
en matière de réduction de ses émissions
de gaz à effet de serre les sujets qui
viennent d'être évoqués par exemple sur
l'avion on le voit 0 effets réels
surtout avec eux et les frais des
mensonges qui permettent de dire que
quand on est dans correspondance on peut
quand même prendre l'avion sur la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
une modification des règles de calcul
des émissions et des consommations qui
font que l'accès recule encore par
rapport à l'existant
non on est devant une grande
mystification mais c'est la preuve que
en matière d'environnement
monsieur macro est vraiment très très
très très vieux monde
il est d'une certaine manière l'otage et
ça a été dit dans votre reportage
juste avant il est l'otage en réalité
des lobbys qui ne veulent absolument pas
qu'on puisse toucher à leur profit et
donc toute mesure qui se ferait au
bénéfice de l'humanité mais au détriment
du profit et rejeter systématiquement
pourtant yves contassot il ya voilà
certaines dispositions qui font grincer
des dents alors vais pas pleurer sur les
collectionneurs de vieilles voitures ont
sans doute mais enfin voilà il ya sept
disposition qui dit que les
collectionneurs de vieilles voitures
n'auront plus le droit d'aller dans les
villes en certains sans s'en émeuve on
est un petit peu dans le cognitif c'est
ce qu'on reproche parfois d'ailleurs au
vert c'est tout simplement d'interdire
son sommation voilà d'entrer dans la
liberté des gens la première des
libertés
la première des libertés c'est de
pouvoir vivre or là nous le savons
aujourd'hui avec la pollution
atmosphérique ses quarante mille morts
par an en france avec la destruction de
la biodiversité ses victimes en toute
une partie du monde végétal et animal
qui disparaît et si l'avenir de
l'humanité ni plus ni moins qui est mise
en cause
alors évidemment ceux qui sont dans
l'égoïsme de court terme disent tant pis
pour nos enfants nos petits-enfants se
débrouilleront et puis si l'humanité
disparaît dans quelques milliers
d'années probablement pas d'ici la fin
du siècle évidemment et bien moi je
serai plus là pour le voir donc cet
égoïsme est absolument abjecte n'y a pas
d'autre mot et je crois qu'il faut au
contraire que l'on fasse comprendre que
c'est notre avenir collectif qui est en
jeu et non pas du tout une punition
on peut très bien vivre avec un
chauffage dans sa maison à 20 ou 21
degrés plutôt que 22 ou 23 degrés comme
c'est la moyenne aujourd'hui on l'oubli
mais on est dans un gâchis absolu
on n'est pas obligé d'avoir des
appareils qui tombent en panne
systématiquement au bout de deux ou
trois ans dès qu'il ya la fin de la
garantie
on n'est pas obligé d'avoir des voitures
qui surconsomment alors qu'il ya eu des
milliards donnés aux constructeurs pour
arriver à fabriquer des voitures avec
moins de consommation inférieur à 2
litres aux cent donc on voit bien que
les solutions sont connues il n'ya pas
la volonté politique
alors on parle aussi de l'interdiction
des voitures de critères 3 dans les
grandes agglomérations
il faut aussi se mettre à la place des
gens promouvez
le diesel avant et maintenant on leur
dit débrouille débrouillez vous avec vos
voitures autres on n'a pas forcément les
moyens de s'acheter une nouvelle voiture
et donc vous avez raison vous avez
raison il y a eu pendant des années et
des années et y compris à gauche
des tas de gens je me souviens de madame
ségolène royal faisant vraiment
panégyrique du diesel alors qu'on le
savait déjà que c'était une catastrophe
et qu'il faudrait l'interdire un jour ou
l'autre
bien oui à gauche comme à droite il ya
des gens qui n'ont pas voulu regarder la
réalité en face et on le sait depuis
très longtemps quand on reporte les
décisions elles sont plus compliquées
alors aujourd'hui il faut accompagner
les gens je suis d'accord surtout parce
que ce sont souvent les plus pauvres qui
ont le plus de mal à changer leur
véhicule et il faut sans doute interdire
les très gros véhicules très polluants
au bénéfice d'une aide à ceux qui sont
absolument contraints d'utiliser leur
véhicule
quelques compositions clairement de la
convention citoyenne ont pas été retenu
mais creek selon vous était
indispensable mais il y en a tellement
que c'est compliqué vous savez sur les
149 la plupart près de 80% ont été d'une
certaine manière soit détournée réécrite
avec en réalité un objectif contraire à
ce qui était proposé quelques unes sont
mises en oeuvre mais avec une
restriction dans la mise en oeuvre la
question de l'aviation qui est une des
pires je dirais en matière d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et d'une
certaine manière symbolique
on le sait aujourd'hui il faudra
interdire les vols
lorsqu'il y a moyen de déplacement en
train qui est en gros de l'ordre de 4
las aurait du sens mais à à 2h30 et avec
cette histoire de correspondance ça n'a
aucun impact d'un élément c'est la
priorité des priorités la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments
et là encore pas grand chose avec des
changements sans arrêt tous les ans sur
les règles fiscales sur les aides qui
sont apportées une année on considère
qu'on peut changer les fenêtres l'année
d'après on peut plus etc
ça n'est pas sérieux vous êtes vous
satisfait en revanche de la proposition
de baisse 1 delà de la tva sur les
billets de trains que d'ailleurs le
gouvernement et les députés n'avaient
pas voulu mais c'est tout à fait
indispensable si aujourd'hui on veut
redonner toute sa place aux déplacements
en train il faut effectivement arriver à
ce qu'on ait une terrasse très réduit
mais j'ajoute que dans le même temps il
faudrait impérativement re développer le
fret ferroviaire
rien n'est fait dans ce domaine rien
n'est fait mais je rappelle que le
premier transport routier français c'est
la sncf à travers ses filiales
donc là encore double discours merci
contassot monde génération est d'avoir
été avec nous sur rt france de
l'actualité en suisse les citoyens
étaient invités hier à se prononcer sur
un certain nombre de questions
environnementales sanitaires et
sécuritaires
si la suppression des pesticides de
synthèse a été largement repoussé la loi
sur les mesures policières de lutte
contre le terrorisme en revanche été
approuvés
une nouvelle mesure qui fait déjà
polémique t au combat
c'est par référendum que la
confédération helvétique renforce sa
législation antiterroriste dimanche les
suisses ont participé à une série de
votation concernant des sujets aussi
divers que l'environnement
le coc u19 ou encore la sécurité si les
débats dans le pays ont été vampirisée
par les propositions de loi concernant
l'interdiction des pesticides de
synthèse celui sur le renforcement des
mesures policières contre le terrorisme
n'est pas passée inaperçue
j'ai voté contre car je les trouvais
trop flagrantes et trop véhémente
mais comme je les dis c'est mon opinion
et je pense que beaucoup de citoyens
suisses pensent que quelque chose doit
être fait et qu'il faut un peu plus de
fermeté
je ne pense pas qu'il s'agisse d'une loi
antiterroriste sévère il s'agit surtout
de pouvoir travailler de manière
préventive et je pense que c'est
important
approuvé à plus de 56 % des voix ce
texte donne des pouvoirs inédits à la
police en matière de lutte préventive
contre le terrorisme une attaque pour
les libertés fondamentales pour
l'opposition ce que dément le conseil
fédéral suisse
le risque zéro n'existe pas mais lorsque
l'on constate qu'il ya des lacunes
il faut les combler et ces nouvelles
mesures ne s'appliquerait qu'aux cas
extrêmes
je ne crois pas qu'il y aura de dérapage
de la part de la police il existe de
nombreux garde-fous
cette loi qui permettra à la police de
surveiller de limiter les déplacements
et d'obliger les terroristes potentiels
à participer à des entretiens et ce dès
l'âge de 12 ans
des mesures qui pourront être prises
dans la plupart des cas sans l'aval d'un
juge
autre problème la définition du
terrorisme
figurant dans le texte est jugé trop
large par ses opposants
ces derniers craignent que les
activistes notamment environnementaux
soient visés une future législation qui
fait grincer des dents à l'onu la suisse
aura désormais la loi antiterroriste la
moins professionnelle la plus inefficace
et la plus dangereuse du monde
un embarras majeur pour la suisse en
tant qu'etat de droit
parmi les autres référendums lee suisse
ont également approuvé une nouvelle loi
renforçant les compétences du
gouvernement en matière de lutte contre
le colis de 19
en revanche les textes réclamant
l'interdiction des pesticides de
synthèse et les subventions aux
agriculteurs les utilisant ont été
rejetée par une large majorité de
suisses
les restrictions sanitaires continuent
d'être allégé dans le cadre du plan de
relance européen 672 milliards d'euros
de subventions et de prêts doivent être
répartis à partir de début juillet entre
les 27
si chaque état doit notamment consacrer
une part de ces investissements la
transition écologique et dans les faits
c'est a priori autre chose c'est ce que
montre le green recovery tracker un
outil d analyse des plans nationaux des
états européens
les explications en images
[Musique]
pour
le
[Musique]
bon
on
[Musique]
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous partirons en israël pour parler du
nouveau gouvernement entré en fonction
le 1er son my amis netanyahu depuis 12
ans et puis nous évoquerons l'algérie
plongé dans l'incertitude au lendemain
de législatives largement boudés par la
population
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui ne va pas dans les
relations entre la russie et l'europe
lui venir travailler en russie nouer des
partenariats pose des problèmes dans la
mesure où vous pouvez être confronté à
un partenaire qui est sous sanction
notamment américaines le commerce de ce
développement
maintenant il ya encore ils ont fait
entre la france je pensais la réussite
maintenant elle joue très russe trouve à
dire que la russie produit rue c'est ce
que ça veut dire qu'il pourrait
s'affranchir de la surpuissance des gaza
par exemple s'affranchisse de la
technologie européenne pour pour tous se
développer des entreprises françaises
qui ont un futur en russie ce sont
celles qui peuvent leur apporter à
savoir faire après la question et ça va
parce qu'elles resteront
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple sap
est une volonté collectés vous le savez
comme moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend vous soyez déçu
l'univers uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté vous
remercie d'avoir amitié
[Musique]
m
un féminicide et commis tous les deux à
trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il sous ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent aux
femmes
oser en parler briser le silence nous
savons que seulement 18 19 % des femmes
révèle les violences qu'elles subissent
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes
qui ne révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité
donc celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment
les croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans les oui la guerre est
possible il ya de multiples façons
d'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]
elle venait
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce lundi 14 points l'otan resserre ses
rangs premier sommet de l'alliance à
bruxelles pour joe biden qui appelle à
affronter les nouveaux défis posés par
la russie et la chine
une déclaration du président américain
qui intervient deux jours avant sa
rencontre avec son homologue russe
l'ennemi poutine à genève
nous avons une opposition un forte
déterminée à faire tomber ce dangereux
un gouvernement de gauche que ce
gouvernement de l'arnaqué qui tombera
vite benyamin netanyahu campe sur ses
positions lendemain de la formation du
nouveau gouvernement israélien à côté
international de nombreuses réactions
washington moscou bruxelles on félicite
bref talibés net premier ministre
ultra-nationaliste d'une coalition
hétéroclite en birmanie le procès d'un
switch i s'est ouvert aujourd'hui
l'ancienne dirigeante a été renversé par
un coup d'état militaire hercules paix à
de multiples reprises par la junte
deux des sept chefs d'inculpation qui
pèsent sur l'opposante ont été examinés
ce lundi les observateurs dénoncent une
procédure spectacle uniquement motivée
par des raisons politiques
[Musique]
place donc au sommet de l'otan à
bruxelles après le g7 en angleterre ce
week-end deuxième étape de la tournée
européenne de joe biden le président
américain qui appelle les alliés
affronter les nouveaux défis posés par
la russie et la chine ont fait point
avec estelle charge de défier préoccupe
particulièrement l'otan la chine tout
d'abord la montée en puissance de pékin
ses ambitions déclarées et je cite les
politiques coercitif de l'empiré du
milieu ont été au coeur des discussions
et sont au coeur des inquiétudes des
alliés
mais malgré cela l'otan entend maintenir
un dialogue constructif avec la chine
lorsque cela est possible
l'organisation appelle le pays à
respecter ses engagements internationaux
et à agir de manière responsable c'est
en tout cas ce que l'on peut retenir de
la déclaration finale du sommet je vous
repose en écoute et en extrait les
ambitions déclarées de la chine et son
comportement affirmé représentent des
défis systémiques pour l' ordre
international fondé sur des règles et
dans des domaines revêtant de
l'importance pour la sécurité de
l'alliance
et justement pas remis à ces domaines le
volet militaire car la chine accroît
rapidement son arsenal nucléaire peut-on
lire dans la déclaration finale
mais surtout elle coopère militairement
avec elle la russie en participant
notamment aux exercices russe dans les
zone euro atlantique ce qui bien
évidemment renforce l'inquiétude de
l'alliance atlantique
autre sujet de préoccupation la russie
ce qui préoccupe c'est le renforcement
un militaire du pays qui constitue pour
les membres de l'otan je cite une menace
grandissante pour la sécurité de la zone
euro atlantique menace qui participe
aussi à l'instabilité le long des
frontières de l'otan l'organisation qui
appelle moscou à respecter le droit
international auquel cas il n'y aura pas
de retour à la normale et coûté tant que
la russie ne montre pas qu'elles
respectent le droit international et
qu'elle honore ses obligations et
responsabilités internationales
il ne peut y avoir de retour à la
normale l'organisation a aussi et
dénoncé l'intensification des activités
hybride de la russie dont des tentatives
d'ingérences dans les élections à des
pays de l'alliance des compagnes
des informations ou encore des actes de
cyber malveillance les relations avec la
russie ont été largement évoquées ce
week-end également dans les cornouailles
en angleterre lors du premier sommet du
g7 en présentiel depuis près de deux ans
résumé de ces trois jours de diplomatie
internationale avec robin pu elle dit
sourire et une envie d'avancer dont la
même direction c'est la ligne de
conduite que joe biden a tenté de suivre
tout au long du week-end pour sa
première réunion du g7 rendez vous
durant lequel le président américain
avait un objectif principal marqué le
retour du multilatéralisme
après la présidence de donald trump au
terme de trois jours de réunion et des
changes
joe biden en mission reconquête auprès
de ses alliés se félicite de la
direction prise par les pays membres
là nous venons de conclure ce qui a été
une réunion du g7 extraordinaire
collaborative et productive tout le
monde autour de la table a compris à la
fois la gravité et les défis auxquels
nous sommes confrontés ainsi que la
responsabilité de nos fiers démocratie
de se mobiliser et d'agir pour le reste
du monde
c'est à cela que sert le g7 et à
rassembler les démocraties du monde pour
relever les défis auxquels le monde est
confronté et apporter des résultats pour
notre peuple et pour les gens très
franchement partout sur le volet des
relations internationales les dirigeants
du g7 ont notamment tenu à adopter une
position commune vis-à-vis de la russie
dans une déclaration publiée à la fin du
sommet il appelle moscou à cesser ses
activités déstabilisatrices
une prise de position rapidement qu'au
monté par la diplomatie russe les pays
du g7 ont adopté une déclaration commune
qui outre l'appel traditionnelle à la
russie de mettre fin à ces comportements
des stabilisateurs présente un aspect
intéressant
le groupe a exprimé son intérêt pour des
relations stables et prévisibles avec la
fédération de russie
avant il avait pour habitude de dire que
la russie devait être plus stable et
prévisible
maintenant cet objectif est considérée
comme faisant partie des relations
communes c'est-à-dire dépendant de
toutes les parties considérant que notre
prévisibilité et confirmé par les années
et les actes la balle est dans le camp
du g7 qui n'est pas parti
clairement bon dans ce domaine la russie
qui sera certainement au coeur des
sujets abordés par joe biden lors de sa
tournée européenne
le président américain doit s'entretenir
avec ursula von der leyen et charles
michel à bruxelles mardi avant une
rencontre très attendue avec vladimir
poutine prévue à genève mercredi
et c'est joe biden poursuit sa tournée
européenne outre atlantique s'est fait
ces ges ne manque pas d'interpeller
l'ancien président américain donald
trump
la réunion du g7 le week end dernier et
les échanges entre le locataire de la
maison blanche emmanuel macron notamment
provoqué son courroux les précisions de
notre reporter taux d'abonnés à
washington sur les images qui ont été
diffusées des différentes rencontres et
discussions lors du g7 on a pu voir
emmanuel macron et joe biden très proche
mettant en scène une complicité voire
même une proximité qui a évidemment un
sens politique
si on ne nie pas le fait que les deux
présidents puisse avoir de bonnes
relations si rapidement on sent que ces
images visait surtout à servir le
discours avancés par les deux hommes à
savoir l'amérique est de retour plus
proche que jamais de ses alliés écoutez
par exemple les propos d' emmanuel
macron dans cette vidéo postée sur son
compte twitter pour tous ces problèmes
nous avons besoin de coopération et je
pense que c'est formidable que le
président américain fasse partie du club
et qu'il soit très désir de coopérer et
je pense que ce que vous démontrez c'est
que le leadership c'est un partenariat
les deux chiffres histoire de chiffres
c'est super d'avoir un président qui
fait partie du club et qui a le souci de
vouloir coopérer cette phrase a
particulièrement retenu l'attention d'un
observateur de marque puisqu'il s'agit
de donald trump l'ancien président
américain étant privé de ses réseaux
sociaux c'est par le biais d'un
communiqué qu'il a vivement réagi
directement contre les propos de madame
à couettes lui et beaucoup d'autres
dirigeants avant lui en france et dans
toute l'europe arnaquer les états unis
comme jamais auparavant
il aime baden parce que maintenant ils
seront autorisés à reprendre leurs
anciennes méthodes d'escroquerie
si j'étais un dirigeant de ces pays moi
aussi je préférais by des anneaux
président trump
critique et très virulente de la part de
l'ancien président visant notamment à
s'attaquer à la diplomatie naissante de
joe by denis mais ces attaques ciblent
aussi emmanuel macron avec qui les
relations ont parfois été compliqué il
ya eu des hauts et des bas entre donald
trump
emmanuel macron se souvient d'abord de
la relation spéciale telle qu'elle était
présentée à l'époque avec notamment ce
fameux dîner à la tour eiffel où il y
avait les deux présidents entourés de
leurs compagnes macron qui avait
également tenté de se placer en
interlocuteurs européens privilégié de
donald trump
mais les désaccords avaient finalement
ressurgit assez vite a notamment à
l'occasion de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies se fait en 2018 à new york
avec notamment la question du changement
climatique et puis il y avait de toute
façon le tempérament tempétueux de
donald trump particulièrement
imprévisibles en termes de diplomatie
alors évidemment on peut comprendre que
les moniales macron préfère le côté plus
calme de joe biden même s'il faudra voir
sur la durée si l'entente n'était
finalement que de façade pour les
photographes ce week end au g7
oui s'il ya des avancées concrètes sur
des dossiers il a navigué à droite de
son ex mentor benyamin nétanyahou et le
voilà devenu le nouvel homme fort
d'israël naftali bennet devenu hier le
premier ministre à la faveur d'une
coalition qui a obtenu le vote de
confiance de la knesset
elles sont nées donc fini de l'air
netanyahu dans les rues de jérusalem et
tel-aviv les israéliens ont laissé
exploser leur joie ont fait le point
avec françois xavier lambert petit chat
[Applaudissements]
les mêmes à téléch années peuvent
atterrir à bel air l'annnonce de la
victoire après 11 jours d'attentes les
applaudissements résonnent dans
l'enceinte de la knesset
hier soir benyamin nétanyahou n'a pas pu
compter sur un ralliement de dernière
minute la coalition hétéroclite mis sur
pied par yaïr lapid est approuvée par 60
députés
visage fermé le premier ministre sortant
observe les nouveaux membres du
gouvernement prêter serment à commencer
par celui qui va prendre la tête de
l'exécutif israélien pour les deux
prochaines années
l'une des figures de la droite
nationaliste naftali bennet année naftal
est bonne
[Applaudissements]
l'annoncé de ce changement de
gouvernement a provoqué des scènes de
liesse à jérusalem des milliers
d'israéliens s'étaient donné rendez vous
pour célébrer le départ de benyamin
nétanyahou
nous avons traversé quatre campagne
électorale mouvementée
[Musique]
nous attendions ce moment je suis sans
voix
[Musique]
nous devons comprendre que nous avons le
pouvoir et le privilège de faire bouger
les choses et pas seulement de rester à
l'écart en espérant que les choses
s'améliorent mais faire quelque chose
agir pour y arriver
à peine investi le nouveau gouvernement
s'est réuni pour présenter les grandes
lignes de son programme
côte à côte naftali bennett et yaïr
lapid se disent prêts à gouverner
ensemble malgré leurs divergences pour
que ce gouvernement fonctionne
nous devons tous observé de la retenue
et mettre à distance les aspects
idéologiques ce qui a fondé ce
gouvernement c'est l'amitié et la
confiance est ce qui va maintenir ce
gouvernement et l'amitié et la confiance
si nous savons comment nous faire
confiance et nous soutenir mutuellement
et travailler ensemble pour que cela
fonctionne cela fonctionnera selon
l'accord de gouvernement naftali bennet
passera le relais à la tête de
l'exécutif à yaïr lapid dans deux ans
les deux hommes savent que leur
coalition allant de la gauche à la
droite nationaliste reste fragile les
huit partis qui la composent vont devoir
s'entendre sur de nombreux sujets
brûlants conflit avec les palestiniens
question du nucléaire iranien ou encore
relance économique post pandémie autant
de sujets qui apparaissent comme les
principaux défis de ce cabinet l'une de
ses premières décisions pourrait déjà
s'avérer crucial le maintien ou non
d'une marche organisée par la droite
radicale ce mardi à jérusalem
le hamas a déjà menacé israël de
représailles si ce rassemblement se
produisent et l ancien premier ministre
benyamin nétanyahou a donc promis de
renverser le gouvernement à la première
occasion lors d'une réunion des partis
d'opposition de la knesset jérusalem
aujourd'hui regardés et coutumes il y à
de nombreuses contradictions raison
d'être est la prévenue mais on ne peut
pas être soutenus ce cas avec une telle
haine
il est impossible de revenir à
gouvernement longtemps celui qui a
remporté six sièges dans un acte de
fraude de droite à gauche peut tromper
et former un gouvernement temporaire
mais pas plus nous allons donc
il a affronté avec une position forte
renverser ce gouvernement à la première
occasion qui est plus proche plus que
vous pensez et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis tel aviv avec
pour l'asl ailleurs journée sport rt
international conçoit en direct sur arte
france vous êtes donc à tel aviv
on aurait vu des scènes de liesse de la
parole à des contres des antilles
netanyahu le changement de gouvernement
le départ de ce premier ministre a
provoqué en tout cas beaucoup de
réaction est tout à fait de nombreuses
réactions
il a fait mention d'un titre il ya eu
des scènes de liesse parmi les partisans
du centre et de la gauche mais environ
60 % du public à voter pour la droite du
spectre politique
cette partie du spectre politique se
retrouve maintenant dans l'opposition il
ya beaucoup de colère d'incompréhension
au sein de ces partis de droite et les
personnes que j'ai interviewés se
sentent trahis par naftali bennett qui a
quitté la droite et rejoint une
coalition avec la centre et le gauche
afin de devenir le prochain premier
ministre israélien
donc la société est très divisée les
images actuelles nous vient du centre
principal de tel aviv des chanteurs des
personnes tubes et entier se sont
rassemblés afin de célébrer ce nouveau
gouvernement sans benyamin nétanyahou
mais il ya d'autres images dans d'autres
régions du pays où des centaines de
personnes par exemple sont rassemblés
devant les murs de notation afin de
prier contre ce nouveau gouvernement
donc ce nouveau ministre se livre au
gouvernement en beaucoup de pain sur la
planche
alors avant de s'intéresser à ce nouveau
gouvernement tout de même un mot sur ses
12 ans d'ère netanyahu que
retiendra-t-on même si c'est pas facile
à résumer que retiendra-t-on de son
bilan en afrique mais de gens se
rappelleront de lui comme d'un dirigeant
très fort il était très explicites
contre l'iran et quel que soit le côté
du spectre politique de l'israélien en
question tous sont unis contre l'iran il
considère
c'est la grande menace contre israël la
plupart des israéliens sont heureux sont
satisfaits de ses propos contre le
pouvoir nucléaire iranien et il ne
devrait pas y avoir de changement pour
le gouvernement actuel
il reste une figure contesté au sein de
certains pans de la société il a été
critiqué car il a refusé de passer la
main alors qu'il fait face à un procès
pour corruption c'est le premier
ministre israélien à être impliqué dans
un procès pour corruption alors qu'il
est encore et pouvoir on l'a accusé
d'avoir essayé de faire jouer cette
situation politique afin de servir ses
propres intérêts d'un autre côté pour
être juste on se rappellera également de
lui comme du premier ministre qui a
conclu quatre accords de normalisation
avec quatre pays arabes tels que le
soudan l'arabie saoudite le bahreïn et
le maroc
donc c'est un bilan partagé et en
fonction de à qui on demande la mémoire
est très différente alors naftali
bennett un il est le tout nouveau
premier ministre israélien qui est il en
crise
c'est une personnalité qui n'est pas
connue sur la scène internationale les
cela fait au moins une décennie qui
travaillent en politique israélienne il
vient du secteur privé c'est ce qu'on
appelle un self made man un millionnaire
de la tech et le premier ministre
orthodoxe de l'histoire d'israël c'est
un juif religieux il a un passeport
américain il parlait anglais très bien
et il a commencé sa carrière politique
au service de benyamin netanyahou il
était chef de son bureau et il son aide
alors que benyamin nétanyahou était dans
l'opposition
cependant leur relation a été très
instable au cours des années et au cours
des dernières années il a s'est trouvé à
trois postes différents ministériel il a
annoncé son intention d'être candidat au
poste de premier ministre
tout récemment alors que benyamin
nétanyahou essayait encore de l'intégrer
dans sa coalition car il représente une
partie de la société encore plus à
droite que benjamin netanyahu naftali
bennett comme on a vu ces redirigé vers
cette coalition du centre et de la
gauche afin de renverser netanyahu alors
il a mis fin à une crise politique de
plus de deux ans tout de même
doit-on s'attendre à une à une vraie
rupture si oui sur quel sujet je ne
pense pas qu'il y aura une véritable
rupture
je ne pense pas que ce gouvernement va
durer plus de quelques semaines
peut-être un mois ou deux opus c'est mon
pronostic c'est également le sentiment
généralisé dans le pays
comme je lai évoqué plus tôt l'aft a ni
naftali bennett a fondé une coalition
extrêmement hétéroclites avec huit
partis différents certains de l'extrême
gauche certains de l'extrême droite
comme le parti du naftali bennet
lui-même
naftali bennet par exemple est opposé à
l'idée d'un état palestinien et le est
partie arabe est en faveur de cet état
palestinien naftali bennett est en
faveur de l'expansion des colonies et la
gauche et les partis arabes sont
contraints donc on ne s'attend pas à ce
que cette coalition dure très longtemps
et on ne s'attend pas non plus à ce que
elles prennent des décisions majeures
sur des sujets
difficile car avec des telles divisions
cela l'amènerait directement à
l'effondrement
on pense donc que la coalition se
concentrera sur des sujets économiques
sur la reconstruction qui serait là
après la crise de l'aco vide et sur le
sujet et rania ce ne sont pas les uns
sujets les plus critiques
merci paul à slayer journée pour rt
internationale en direct de tel aviv ce
soir l'algérie dans la tente de la
proclamation des résultats des
législatives anticipées de samedi l'un
des principaux partis de mouvance
islamiste a revendiqué la victoire
un scrutin largement boudé par les
électeurs avec un taux de participation
autour de 30% seulement on fait quoi
avec ben hassen chébili sur place les
premiers résultats des élections
législatives anticipées algérienne
marqué par un fort taux d'abstention
toujours pas connue ce scrutin le
premier depuis le soulèvement populaire
contre un cinquième mandat de l'ex
président abdelaziz bouteflika a été
boycotté par le mouvement contestataire
du miracle et par une partie de
l'opposition qui y voit qu'une mascarade
électorale tandis que les pro
gouvernement ont appelé à voter
massivement mais de son côté le
président teboul a déclaré que le taux
de participation n'avait pas
d'importance ce qui importe c'est que
les députés élus par le peuple est une
légitimité suffisante c'est en kabylie
au nord du pays que le taux de
participation a été quasi nulle
accompagné de tension et de saccage dur
hier soir le principal parti islamique
en liste le mouvement de la société pour
la paix a revendiqué la victoire selon
un communiqué de ce parti conservateur
considéré comme modéré mais aucun
résultat pour le
moment même provisoire n'a encore été
annoncée en raison du dépouillement
compliqué le chef de l'autorité
nationale indépendante des élections
avait fait savoir samedi que les
résultats officiels pourraient ne pas
être annoncés avant plusieurs jours
à retenir également une large
représentation de la jeunesse en lice
dans ces élections en algérie grâce
notamment à la modification du code
électoral
reportage on retrouve sam shemie avec
nadir sidi ben ali et quentin mauclair
après les élections législatives
algériennes habib a fait une nuit
blanche comme beaucoup de citoyens de
son âge il participe pour la première
fois un scrutin en tant que candidat du
haut de ses 35 ans et après des études à
l'étranger
il a décidé de revenir sur sa terre
natale armée d'espoir et de conviction
pour participer à la construction de la
nouvelle algérie dans l'opposition
depuis neuf ans être aujourd'hui
candidat lui apparaît comme l'étape
cruciale de son engagement politique et
citoyen aujourd'hui je parle pour une
cosse pour la liberté pour les libertés
individuelles et collectives pour la
démocratie et qui fait et j'étais
certain qu'il fallait faire transférer
cet état d'esprit et transférer ses
positions déjà dans le débat public mais
aussi dans les institutions élues pour
pouvoir finalement changer les lois et
permettre à ces idées d'arriver sur le
terrain des de la pratique depuis le lac
nous avons vu l'entrée de
en politique ou un intérêt nouveau pour
la politique des algériens des jeunes
algériens et nous avons dit qu'il ne
suffisait pas de sortir dans la rue
marché mais qu'il fallait transférer cet
esprit qu'il fallait transférer cet
essai valeur et qu'il fallait transférer
ces visages à l'intérieur des
institutions des élus et c'est ce que ce
que nous avons essayé de concrétiser en
présentant le projet de jil jadid à ces
élections pour fatima zohra
ce sont les mêmes aspirations qui l'ont
poussé à embrasser une carrière
politique
journaliste de formation cette jeune
activiste de 29 ans a fait le choix
d'une liste indépendante
pour elle ce qui prime c'est l'algérie
au détriment des enjeux partisans à
travers son engagement elle souhaite
représenter une jeunesse politisée et
avide de changement
je veux être indépendante pour être
libre libre avec mes idées parce que les
partis politiques
ils ont des idées déjà ils ont une
structure etc
pour un jeune algérien qui a des idées
nouvelles
alors on voulait donner un plus pas
qu'on suit le même système quoi alors on
voulait vraiment qu'on donne et personne
ne nous contrôlent ce qu'on fait pour la
jeunesse on a vu le disent pas et on
voulait vraiment autant que gêne quand
on fait quelque chose de plus pour la
gerle c'est le moment pour les élites de
rentrer dans les aliments
du côté des partis pro gouvernementaux
nombreux sont ceux qui ont fait le choix
de s'engager aux côtés de formations
déjà bien ancré dans le paysage
politique algérien c'est le cas
d'abderrazak 36 ans professeur à
l'université et candidat du mouvement el
bina le parti de la construction
pour ce militant l'implication des
jeunes issus de l'élite intellectuelle
algérienne est un acquis important
de quoi apporter un souffle nouveau à
l'appareil politique et au processus de
développement du pays
on voulait rendre le minimum à notre
gouvernement par la participation des
jeunes surtout après le changement du
code électoral qui a encouragé les
jeunes
à cette occasion je félicite monsieur le
président de la république afdel
m'agiter boon qui nous a donné cette
chance et aussi l'autorité nationale et
indépendante des élections qui nous a
promis une élection libre et
indépendante
à partir de là je me suis présenté sur
la liste du parti al bina qui nous a
accueillis et donner la chance de nous
présenter avec un programme donc en tant
que jeunes nous avons essayé de toucher
la jeunesse pour leur dire que nous
construirons ensemble cette nouvelle
algérie
étape par étape pour ces premières
législatives depuis le soulèvement
inédit du 22 février 2019
né du rejet d'un cinquième mandat de
l'ex président abdelaziz bouteflika
jamais la jeunesse n'avait été autant
représentée à une élection algérienne
alors que le dépouillement suit son
cours
la jeunesse algérienne engagés semblent
retenir son souffle dans l'espoir de
devenir l'un des 4 107 membres de
l'assemblée populaire nationale et enfin
inscrire leur vision dans la
construction de l'algérie de demain
début du procès de l'ex dirigeant
germann paix de plusieurs chefs
d'accusation par la junte elle risque
plusieurs années de prison et puis nous
évoquerons le gouverneur de la banque du
liban riad salamé justice française a
ouvert une enquête sur le patrimoine
détenu par le cet homme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise
je pense que ça a été bien de continuer
le football pour s'évader un peu aussi
haut niveau au niveau mental
on est tous conscients que le football
ligny tout ce qui est au niveau social
surtout au niveau culture et quel regard
portez-vous sur toutes ces années à
monaco à la juventus en équipe de france
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné en temps
dans tous les contextes et quand on a la
chance de revenir en étant ambassadeur
voir les gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a fait
et nantes surtout au niveau du beau
football et ça c'est touchant
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
en féminines ici des commis tous les
deux à trois jours en france
actuellement
pourquoi il joue ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent
femmes osé en parler
briser le silence nous savons que
seulement 18 19 % des femmes révèle les
violences qu'elles subissent donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes qui ne
révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité dont
celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment les
croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
[Musique]
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur arte
france si vous nous rejoignez en
birmanie ouverture du procès de l'ex
dirigeante aung san suu kyi qui a été
renversé par un coup d'état militaire
est inculpé à de multiples reprises par
la junte
le procès aura lieu dans un tribunal de
la nouvelle capitale et devrait durer
jusqu'au 26 juillet la dame de rangoon
encore jusqu'à plusieurs années de
prison si elle est reconnue coupable
les observateurs dénoncent eux une
procédure spectacle uniquement motivée
par des raisons politiques
auxonne dans msci est en bonne santé
comme avant bien qu'elle soit en bonne
santé elle dit qu'elle souffre d'un mal
de dents en général elles semblent avoir
bonne mine comme avant le procès a
débuté à 10h 20 win min a été le premier
à témoigner au procès
l' affaire concernant la loi sur la
gestion des catastrophes naturelles
était la première affaire à être traité
et on en parle avec le rôle de blanche
maison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous pour bien
comprendre soir projetant concrètement à
la dame de rangoon
alors la police aurait trouvé à son
ancien domicile à des talkie walkie
elle aurait trouvé aussi à un brouilleur
démission et puis le procureur lui
reproche de ne pas avoir respecté toutes
les règles de confinement lors de la
campagne électorale de l'année dernière
du mois d'octobre dernier
et puis plus sérieusement on lui
reproche d'avoir détourné des fonds
publics pour construire une maison et
enfin on lui reproche une correction
elle aurait touché 600 mille dollars et
11 kilos d'or à titre de d'un paiement
en cours pour services rendus donc une
corruption
alors évidemment certains certains c'est
cette batterie de d'accusation est
destiné à éliminer
évidemment on s'en soucie du paysage
politique
c'est l'objectif de la junte qui veut
l'écarter tout à fait et effectivement
avec les deux dernières accusations qui
sont très graves corruption et bien la
junte cherchait à ternir l'image de
l'icône l'image de du prix nobel de la
paix 91 et à la dans le faux nuire à sa
notoriété à la fois au sein de l'opinion
publique birmane et à l'étranger il
n'est pas sûr que cela réussisse
en effet il semble bien que les
manifestations se poursuivent et que la
junte soit la seule à croire que ce
procès pourrait lui rapporter quelque
chose en terme politique où on est le
pays la birmanie aujourd'hui
alors sur le plan interne les choses
vont évidemment très mal puisque
l'économie est à l'arrêt il ya toujours
des manifestations
le système bancaire ne fonctionne plus
il y à une obéissance civile généralisée
dans les écoles dans les universités et
on voit aussi un phénomène
inflationniste
le prix de l'essence augmenté de 25 %
depuis le 1er février c'est à dire
depuis le coup d'état et les produits
essentiels venant à manquer le
gouvernement les militaires ont dû lever
toutes les licences d'importation est
également toutes les taxes à
l'importation marque pour que les
produits de première nécessité aliments
médicaments puissent entrer sur le
territoire birman donc la situation est
très mauvaise sur le plan international
ça ne va pas mieux puisque même la chine
qui soutient le régime birman s'inquiète
maintenant du fait que certaines usines
chinoises ont été attaqués par les
manifestants qui justement accusent la
chine de soutenir le régime et que ce
que veut surtout la chine
c'est que le calme ne revienne pour
continuer à faire des affaires en
birmanie et puis par ailleurs l'asian
les pays d'asie du sud-est puisque la
birmanie est l'un des dix pays membres
l'association du sud est asiatique et
que le 24 avril dernier le général chef
de la junte avait accepté de se rendre à
un sommet à jakarta où il avait été un
peu sermonner mais finalement il avait
évité une condamnation en acceptant une
médiation en acceptant qu'il y ait un
médiateur de désigner cette médiation et
bien elle a été exercée en pure perte
par le secrétaire-général de l'asian
accompagné du midd affaires étrangères
de broussailles qui exerce actuellement
la présidence du conseil des mises à
faire d'étrangères de laval
ils ont été il ya quelques jours en
birmanie ils ont vu les officiels bien
entendu ils n'ont pas eu accès à
l'opposition nie avoir eu tant de succès
ni aux autres opposants qui sont soit en
prison soit à l'étranger et par
conseiller
dans cette mission n'a pas à ce stade
servi à grand chose donc le régime et
est virtuellement isolé est en fait le
plus clair de le résultat le plus clair
de l'ouverture de ce procès c'est qu'on
ne compte pas les plus des généraux et
la répression qui a fait 900 morts en
quatre mois
depuis quelques semaines et même depuis
deux mois on n'en parlait plus dans
l'impasse occidentale et bien à partir
d'aujourd'hui on en repart dernière
question tombe blanche raison la junte
militaire est ce qu'elle parviendra à
ses fins elle vient aujourd'hui de se
tirer une balle dans le pied ce qui pour
les militaires est un peu un comble
parce que en effet il y à un certain
nombre de députés qui était élu à cette
assemblée qui a été donc 10 août à cette
assemblée élue avec en grande majorité
des membres du parti de madame ton de ce
qui est certains de ses députés ont
formé un gouvernement en exil
ce gouvernement en exil est formé de
jeunes députés qui réfléchissent à
l'avenir et qui pensent que à l'avenir
il faut sans doute faire évoluer la
constitution birmane vers une
constitution fédérale
il faut par conséquent prendre langue
avec les minorités ethniques ce qu'ils
font minorités ethniques qui se sont
révoltés contre les généraux contre la
junte et prendre langue avec elle pour
des voir dans quelle mesure il pourrait
y avoir un régime beaucoup plus inclusif
par la suite une fois que la junte aura
été obligé de passer la main donc les
généraux sont en train d'éliminer madame
santschi du champ politique alors que
finalement il avait les accommodements
avec elle et que l avait couvert leurs
agissements
à propos des rohingya à propos de
l'expulsion les musulmans rohingya et
ils vont se retrouver soi sans
interlocuteur soit avec des
interlocuteurs beaucoup plus difficile
ce gouvernement en exil qui cherche à
être reconnu sur le plan international
d'abord par les pays de la zale ensuite
par les autres pays de la région
peut-être que la chine à un moment donné
l'un d'eux chercheront à faire rebondir
la la
la médiation de l'asian pour ramener les
militaires birmans à la raison est
arrivé à un dialogue avec l'opposition
il débouche sur une solution
démocratique
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
le gouverneur de la banque du liban est
l'une des personnalités politiques les
plus controversés du pays après la
justice suisse c'est au tour de la
justice française d'enquêter sur le
patrimoine immobilier de riad salamé
l'avocat de ce dernier a estimé qu'il
s'agissait d'une manipulation et d'une
opération politique plus d'explications
avec monnet à monter l'or alors que le
liban fait face à l'une des pires crises
financières du monde depuis le milieu du
19e siècle selon la banque mondiale
riad salamé gouverneur de la banque
centrale du pays et proche du clan
hariri est considérée par de nombreux
libanais comme étant à l'origine de
nombreuses malversations financières qui
à leurs yeux on appauvrit le pays au fil
des décennies après une plainte suisses
et françaises lankais du parquet
national financier le pnf s'intéresse
aux très riche patrimoine immobilier du
gouverneur et qui s'élèverait à plus de
50 millions d'euros selon une enquête du
mensuel alternatives économiques
riad salamé homme d'affaires chevronnés
collectionnerait les appartements de
luxe à paris
ces révélations sont à l'origine de la
transposition d'une directive européenne
par le luxembourg en 2019 et qui a
permis de rendre publique l'identité des
bénéficiaires réels de société est
détenue par réel salée mais ses proches
le gouverneur de la banque du liban
possèderait plusieurs appartements et
studios à neuilly sur seine une villa à
antibes et trois restaurants et pour
agrandir son patrimoine réel salée mais
aurait eu recours au clan familial
riad salamé bien trop rusé pour avoir
investi en son nom propre
c'est pourquoi il a eu recours à des
sociétés off shore en plaçant des
membres de sa famille à la tête de ces
structures
plusieurs membres de sa famille
apparaîtrait comme actionnaire
secondaires de ces biens mary al salam
et serait bien l'actionnaire principal
l'homme âgé de 70 ans aurait réparti ses
biens auprès d'au moins sept personnes
de son clan familial huit appartements
serait situé dans le 8ème
le 16e arrondissement de paris pour un
montant total qui s'élèverait à 23
millions d'euros
selon l' enquête d'alternatives
économiques riad salamé serait également
à la tête de différentes entreprises et
trois d'entre elles sont pointées du
doigt par les enquêtes judiciaires pour
l'achat de plus de 10 millions d'euros
de biens immobiliers en allemagne en
belgique et au royaume uni
l'une d'entre elle détient un patrimoine
immobilier valant 14,3 millions d'euros
dont deux appartements situés avenue
georges mandel puis de trois étages de
bureaux au 66 avenue des champs-elysées
selon françois el bacha économiste et
fondateur de libnanews cette plainte n'a
rien de surprenant si on regarde à peu
près les dépêches wikileaks publié il ya
quelques années quand même on trouvait
déjà les éléments de cette plainte
donc c'est pas quelque chose qui est
surprenant c'est que c'est une chose au
contraire c'est le ce qui est surprenant
c'est qu'on a mis autant de temps à à ce
qu'on puisse sortir ces éléments au
public
le système judiciaire libanais en fin de
compte les gangréné et le procureur
général de la république comme riad
salamé est un proche de saad hariri
donc automatiquement ils avaient tous un
t on avec tous intérêts entre guillemets
dans ce système dans cette nébuleuse à
ne pas vraiment à ce que le système
judiciaire libanais ne puisse pas se
mettre en branle en fin de compte
mary est salée mais ni ces chiffres au
quotidien le monde il explique que ses
avoirs personnels s'élevait à 10,9
millions d'euros lorsqu'il a pris ses
fonctions en 1993 et que son
enrichissement personnel et depuis le
résultat de nombreux investissements
ce sera à la justice française de
tranchées de déterminer avec quel argent
ces biens ont été acquis au pays du
cèdre
cette enquête donne un peu d'espoir mais
le pnf tient à son indépendance
vis-à-vis du gouvernement français et
n'a pas vocation à faire bouger la
situation politique au liban
la france avait annoncé une vague de
sanctions contre les politiques libanais
reste à savoir si ryad salem et figure
sur cette liste
en attendant le liban continue de
sombrer dans l'une des pires crises
économiques et sociales jamais connue
par le pays
et la population se paupérise davantage
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis beyrouth avec françois el bacha
économise fondateur de libre linda news
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir françois el bacha merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on vous a vu vous exprimer dans ce
reportage
l'enquêté ouverte par le parquet
national financiers s'ajoute à deux
plaintes déposées au uk et au liban les
taux clermont se resserre autour de riad
salamé bonsoir c'est pas au liban au
liban il ya une enquête effectivement
mais c'est en suisse et en angleterre au
libor la plainte concerne plutôt disons
voir c'est le scandale de la
manipulation du cours de la livre
libanaise où il ya aussi maintenant une
ouverture d'une enquête à la demande de
la justice française va justice suisse
donc oui je vous en prie vous allez
vas-y mon coeur y est c'est la mériter
de gestionnaire de fortune de rafic
hariri qui l'a nommé par la suite à la
tête de la banque centrale libanaise
cela clermont ne pose pas un problème de
conflit d'intérêts effectivement cela
cela fait envie d'en tirer puisque la
famille hariri possède 10% des actions
de toutes les banques libanaises donc
qu'on peut pas mon âme à la fois un juge
et un arbitre dans ce cas là et 43% de
la peau des hommes de la classe
politique est impliqué aussi dans
l'actionnariat des banques libanaises et
donc automatiquement le parlement est
aussi partie prenante au détriment de
l'intérêt des déposants par exemple et
on a dernièrement la loi sur le contrôle
des capitaux on voit bien que les
parlementaires ont pratiquement tout
déléguer comme tout ce qui est
décisionnel à la banque du liban
c'est clairement l'illustration l'image
de la corruption qui règne dans le pays
depuis déjà plusieurs années 1
il y a de fortes chances
que la banque du liban un audit
juricomptable de la banque du liban
révèle certaines choses certaines zones
au mali on peut parler pour le moment
des anomalies on peut pas parler
réellement de détournement de fond ça
c'est l' enquête qui débute qui le
déterminera
mais autant qu'on sache s'il ya
certaines anomalies déjà sur le plan
comptable par rapport à l'audi normal
qui a été publié là quelque chose qui a
été publiée l'année dernière de ses
comptes
les libanais en tout cas l'accusant riad
salamé d'être carrément responsables de
la crise économique qui frappe durement
le pays
ces accusations vous semble-t-elle
recevable ça oui ça il ya c'est
quelqu'un qui reste et depuis très
longtemps la tête de la banque du liban
c'est lui qui a formulé la politique
monétaire de la banque dont on est dans
une crise aujourd'hui qui
essentiellement financières
c'est simplement le fait d'avoir gardé
une monnaie surévaluée pendant 25 ans
sans aucun ajustement sans aucune
dévaluation progressive de la libanaise
pour justement attirer des fonds de
l'étranger pourra pour conserver des
fonds de l'étranger et ainsi de suite et
jusqu'à ce que le système s'effondre de
lui-même
certains hommes politiques étrangers
comme emmanuel macron lors de son
déplacement au liban n'ont pas hésité à
parler de schéma ponzi qu'un schéma de
fraude en fin de compte et ça c'est du
ressort de la banque du liban mais il
faut quand même rappeler effectivement
que sa fortune dépasserait les 2
milliards de dollars alors qu'on ne sait
rien des pires crises économiques que
connaît le pays
aujourd'hui on imagine qu'il va y avoir
beaucoup de pression sur ces enquêtes
qui pèsent sur lui
il ya deux ans dans une main pendant
local et un pendant internationale le
pendant local jusqu'à maintenant on n'a
pas réussi à marcher tout simplement
parce que la justice libanaise est très
politisée comme on a pu le
le boire dans le reportage c'est une
injustice qui avait déjà été paralysé
l'année dernière dans le cadre des
enquêtes sur la manipulation du cours de
la livre libanaise dans le cadre d'un
contrôle informel des capitaux par les
banques on a vu les banques qui ont des
propriétaires des banques qui ont menacé
de faire grève et grosso modo le
procureur de la république à annuler la
décision du procureur financier de
saisie et de nez bien de ses
actionnaires
donc et on espère que grosso modo la
l'anc est apprécié on va pouvoir faire
pression sur le système judiciaire local
pour débloquer les choses faciles de
manière beaucoup plus efficace mais
qu'on lui a mis la pression sur les
dirigeants libanais et pourtant rien ne
semble bouger ça veut dire quoi que la
voix du président français n'a aucun
impact au liban on est dans un système
où il ya beaucoup de résistance et ces
gens là pensent être beaucoup plus
puissants même que la communauté
internationale mais dense dans les
équations actuelle si la communauté
internationale qui détient toutes les
cartes en main on a une situation où
monuc au bord d'un effondrement
économique
on ne les banques selon un rapport
standard and poor's au rythme face à des
pertes de 100 milliards de dollars 143
milliards de dollars de dépôts il n'y a
aucun moyen aujourd'hui à ce que le
système bancaire puisse survivre à long
terme on voit juste qu'ils essaient
simplement de gagner du temps comme en
donnant 400 dollars par mois aux
déposants en cash en devises étrangères
et quelle est l'équivalent de 400 $ en
livres libanaises au taux de la banque
du liban
c'est à dire à de la nouvelle plateforme
électronique d'abord du liban mais cela
augmente la masse monétaire et donc
provoquer une détérioration de la ville
libanaise n'ont aucune marge de
manoeuvre
mais ils veulent pas l'admettre
clairement aujourd'hui riad salamé son
avocat estime qu'il s'agit c'est qu'il
s'agit d'une manipulation et d'une
opération politique
est-ce qu'on peut réellement le croire
on entend beaucoup parler de choses
il ya même des gens qui prétendent que
la justice suisse la justice française
joue la justice anglaise voire même la
justice américaine se fait manipuler par
des partis politiques libanais comme le
hezbollah
ça serait très étonnant que le hezbollah
qui fait l'objet de sanctions
économiques puissent manipuler
c'est un appareil judiciaire français un
appareil judiciaire suisse un appareil
d'une serre même américain donc les
décevoir
laissons les choses faire leurs courses
hui leurs cours déterminer les
responsabilités de chacun et on verra
bien si effectivement la justice
française ouvre une enquête c'est c'est
qu'il ya des éléments quand même qu'ils
sont assez troublant comme la justice
suisse merci beaucoup à françois el
bacha économise fondateur de libnanews
d'avoir été avec nos homélies premier
conseil de cabinet du nouveau
gouvernement ce dimanche une réunion
menée par choguel amelia durant laquelle
ont été dévoilées les chantiers à venir
alors que le pays traverse une période
difficile et détails avec mehdi et ce
qui fit une feuille de route très chargé
qui doit répondre aux priorités fixées
par l'exécutif malien ce dimanche le
nouveau gouvernement s'est réuni autour
de son premier ministre choguel maïga
parmi les participants des personnes
appartenant à la coalition du n 5 et
rêve pays des militaires des politiques
et plusieurs technocrates
au programme de la nouvelle équipe
ministérielle l'organisation d'élections
en vue de ramener les civils à deux
têtes du pays d'ici février 2022
pour cela il serait envisagé la création
d'un organe unique indépendant gestion
des élections il clamé unanimement la
classe politique et la société civile
nommé par le nouveau président de la
transition a sévi great art show qu'elle
moga évoqué ses autres objectifs
améliorer la sécurité et lutter contre
la corruption mener des réformes
politiques et institutionnelles ou
encore répondre aux demandes sociales
le premier ministre a également promis
de poursuivre en justice les
responsables de la répression des
manifestations de juillet 2020 et de
mener à bien la révision de la
constitution
le véritable poursuites judiciaires
consécutives aux séries exactement quand
les victimes des journées tués et 1020
également engagés
la révision consensuelle et inclusive de
la constitution dans le respect de son
article 118 si l'arrêt lecture
intelligente
l'accord pour la paix et la
réconciliation ici le processus d'alliés
dans le respect des principes
fondamentaux énoncés sont poursuivis
approfondi le mali toujours confrontés à
la menace djihadiste alors que la france
a récemment annoncé la fin de
l'opération barkan au sahel
certains citoyens se tournent à présent
vers la russie pour appeler à l'aide
dans la région une demande qui se
matérialise par des rassemblements
réguliers devant l'ambassade russe à
bamako cette option pourrait devenir
plus sérieuses dans les semaines à venir
et c'est la fin de cette émission
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
dans quelques minutes
[Musique]
votre fonction c'est évidemment de
permettre la liaison entre les
entreprises et le marché local andy nous
avons créé un outil qui nous permet
d'avoir accès aux plus hautes autorités
de l'état français de l'état russe et
qui nous permet d'améliorer le climat
d'investissement aussi comment vous
chantez la façon dont les entreprises
vont venir